well Joe Biden siding with Republicans
on crime and a massive flip-flop it's
got liberals melting down that the
president blocked Washington DC from
enacting a law that gives free reign to
criminals by reducing prison sentences
on everything from carjacking to gun
robberies that makes sense Biden insists
he's still on board with D.C statehood
but AOC well she's not buying it she
tweeted this this ain't it DC has a
right to govern itself like any other
state or municipality if the president
supports D.C statehood he should govern
like it in one Anonymous house Democrat
really let loose after many in the party
voted to let the D.C crime law go
through because they thought they had
Biden's backing they texted a reporter
this lovely quote the White House
bleeped this up royally bleeping Amateur
hour head should roll over this and
Kareen Jean-Pierre she seems confused on
why any Democrat would feel like they
got backstabbed
we opposed it but there was no veto
threat the way that we see it is that
this is coming to the president's desk
this is not a legislation that he put
forward D.C is not yet a state even
though he supports D.C statehood and he
had to make a decision and look again we
let the process move forward in Congress
and we felt this was the time to to make
that decision
you know Jesse um carjackings up by 111
percent and the liberal logic is let's
lessen the penalty for carjacking sure
this story is confusing to me
but let me see if I have this straight
Biden is less crazy than DC is this all
the story is yes okay then why are we
doing the story this makes him look good
we should have done something else the
city councils are really the root of
evil in this country and that's not an
overstatement at all because Muriel
Bowser is a kook and Muriel Bowser had
to veto this Kook legislation how crazy
is that so they're getting rid of
mandatory minimum so if you carjack
someone with a pistol the judge has no
discretion you're basically going to get
hit with like a 10 or 15 year since they
just wiped out all mandatory minimums in
that City
so you're basically emptying prisons the
Democrats in the house that a lot of
them voted for this they say they're not
for defunding the police well so what
they're for emptying the prisons because
that's what this is and explain this to
me if if you have uh primarily black
City in DC and you have a primarily
black city council why is the city
council passing bills that are against
the best interest of their black
constituents you you think black DC
residents are clamoring to empty the
prisons so why would they do that are
they assuming that all of their
constituents are criminals and they're
going to like soft sentencing I I still
have not understood why they're doing
this yeah and the administration saw
daylight on this Jessica at first they
put out an administrative statement
saying oh we may veto this and then all
of a sudden it about face I mean did
they see the light or is it politics
it's always politics but it brings us
back to how Joe Biden won the nomination
that actually his political instincts
which are from decades past are better
than a lot of Democrats today so if you
go back to the debates he said can't
have an open border right he said we
can't defund the police I would never
support defunding the police he said we
can't have Medicare for all we can have
a public option because we want everyone
to have some health care but we're not
wiping out the private insurance
companies and guess what he
overwhelmingly won the Primary he went
on to win two general elections running
on his political instincts so when you
see a lot of these bills that are too
left even for some in the Democratic
party they're not usually coming from
him like canceling student debt was not
part of his initial plan who's against
it actually and I understand but I'm
saying that Joe Biden's Compass is
actually much more in line where the
majority of Americans are I think that's
desperate we're desperate because he's
ruled over so many times this is like
finally he didn't all over
to avoid fired this week right Tessa
Boudin fired last year house Democrats
fired because New York House Seats were
picked up by Republicans yeah I mean
look Washington DC is not a state there
are constitutional reasons for that is
the capital of the United States of
America it doesn't belong to the people
who live in DC it belongs to the rest of
the country and people there who people
who want to visit have a right to go to
the capital of their country and feel
safe without getting carjacked without
walking down the street in the middle of
the day and having their jackets ripped
off of them and stolen from them at
gunpoint that is what Americans deserve
so I'm glad that President Biden decided
even if it's for political reasons to
veto this insane legislation that is
completely procriminal when it comes to
the end game though the fact that the
latch is reacting to this it just proves
that they're willing to you know again
the ends justify the means we're fine
with increased carjackings which we see
every single day in Washington DC dozens
of them a week
as long as we get our Democratic state
for political power and purposes they
are willing to sacrifice innocent
victims for the sake of political power
and that's why they're freaking out
about this and the progressives are very
upset Greg um the White House bleeping
bleep this up World royally was at an
anonymous house stem it sounds a lot
like you yeah probably you know DC isn't
a state it's a disease
I had to go back to what Jesse said
because I had written this down do you
ever wonder what these people are really
thinking how do they not see the
suffering and the crime in the
victimization uh from these policies and
yet they double down on these policies
and you can't you have to keep so we we
you have to what is the reasoning like
why like we're not that much different
they they walked down the same streets
they go to the same restaurants they go
to the same gyms they have they have
friends that have been victims of crime
and so so go back I posed this question
uh like a week ago are progressives
unable to understand the science of this
incentives like if they don't get do
they not get it that if you if you lower
these things you create this problem
that's like being mentally disabled
think about it a part of being a human
being is understanding incentives and
disincentives if you don't understand
that you can't survive and you can
destroy a country the other option
though is that they do understand but
they just don't care you gotta you know
break a few eggs or heads you know to
make that you know that radical Utopia
come true yeah incentives uh political
survival seems to be an incentive of the
president heading into 2024. good move
Biden never thought I'd say that hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else